Samsung pourrait bien se prendre un
petit taquet à l'horizon 2023 avec
l'arrivée d'un concurrent très sérieux
au niveau des smartphones qui expliquent
le truc est assez dingue je vous
explique pourquoi
[Musique]
alors je sais pas si vous le savez mais
la plus forte valeur chez Samsung le
smartphone qui je pense à la plus forte
valeur depuis un an et demi c'est le
Samsung Galaxy Z flip zip 3 d'abord puis
zflip 4 le zflip première génération
était bien mignon mais bon il lui manque
encore un certain truc avec le Zig 3 ils
sont arrivés qu'un écran plus grand à
l'extérieur alors le zflip 3 je pense
que vous le savez c'est le smartphone de
Samsung qui vient se plier où vous allez
réduire l'encombrement qu'on va bien
mettre en face du Samsung Galaxy Z fold
4 ou là on va venir augmenter la surface
utile pour arriver sur une petite
tablette et aujourd'hui dans les
smartphones de Samsung celui qui a la
plus forte valeur que les gens vont je
pense le plus aimé parce qu'il est le
plus différent qu'il apporte vraiment de
nouveaux usages c'est le Samsung Galaxy
Z flip 3 ou zflip 4 alors celui qui se
vendra le plus qui fera le plus de
volume je pense que c'est le Samsung
Galaxy a53 c'est du milieu de gamme
c'est un produit qui rassurant qui
marche bien et qui est très bien mais
celui qu'on regarde donc en fait genre
attends c'est quoi ton truc c'est le
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4 parce qu'il
vient se plier parce qu'il est canon
parce qu'il est super c'est un petit
format mais dans la poche il passe
partout et je l'adore il est vraiment
génial et là il vient de passer un truc
absolument démentiel je vous montre ça
regardez c'est oppo alors oppo on
connaît c'est un très grand constructeur
chinois qui fait des smartphones géniaux
je vous ai notamment donné mon coup de
cœur de cette année 2022 c'est le oppo
finding 5 Pro c'est déjà mon coup de
cœur dans la première partie de l'année
c'est également mon coup de cœur dans la
deuxième partie de l'année c'est le
smartphone de l'année pour moi parce
qu'il est super beau en terme de photos
très équilibré ailleurs d'ailleurs je
vous ai fait une vidéo là-dessus allez
jeter un coup d'œil comme ça vous saurez
pourquoi et oppo arrive avec un format
qu'il y a ce plier carrément comme celui
de Samsung Galaxy cette flip 3 ou
Netflix on va dire causé de flippant ce
sera beaucoup plus simple parce que ils
arrivent avec ce truc là et ce truc là
et juste énorme pourquoi et alors déjà
vous retrouver exactement le même format
quasiment la même épaisseur alors je
donne là où le zflip fait 7,9 mm lui
fait 7,65 d'épaisseur donc c'est
quasiment la même chose il fait 191
grammes là où le zflip fait 188G c'est
la même chose l'écran intérieur il fait
16,8 contre 6,7 pour le Z flic donc
c'est le même truc la grosse différence
que vous allez avoir c'est cet écran
extérieur qui est mouse il est énorme il
fait
3,26 on a une énorme diagonale et je
trouve que le truc a vraiment bien fait
ici au pot c'est de faire un choix de
mettre un grand écran là où Samsung vous
met un petit écran de notification et
c'est ça qui va tout changer parce que
quand on va venir choisir un smartphone
alors Samsung ça reste la leader ça
reste la marque fort ça reste la marque
qui rassure ils ont un peu d'avance mais
pour autant au pot c'est un géant en
Chine qui est arrivé il y a quelques
années en France et qui est moins connu
fatalement que Samsung mais qui pour
autant est extrêmement sérieux et le
Montreux parce qu'ils l'ont présenté ce
produit là à Ino days alors inoda je
vous fais très court c'est le temps fort
de l'année de repos il vient de montrer
leurs innovations alors ils ont montré
une nouvelle puce la puce Marie silicone
y qui est là pour l'audio qui aide
vachement intéressant on verra ça
l'année prochaine parce qu'il sera je
pense intégré dans le find Dick 6 Pro
fallix 6 pro je pense d'ailleurs ils ont
également présenté un produit plus pour
la santé collecté ils ont présenté deux
produits le finden 2 c'est celui-là
c'est un smartphone qui ressemble un
petit peu plus au Galaxy Z fold 4
d'ailleurs je vous avais déjà présenté
le finden début d'année 2022 qui était
un smartphone très cool j'aime beaucoup
le faux Galaxy Z fold
très agréable à venir utiliser donc
c'est un très très joli produit et puis
la version 2 aussi à être extrêmement
canon donc ça c'est cool on le voit
d'ailleurs tout travail ils ont montré
différents plans pour voir la charnière
comment elle est fabriquée une fois de
plus on retrouve ici un Snapdragon 8
plus Jen 1 bon bref je vous passe un peu
le truc c'est un joli smartphone mais le
truc qui nous intéresse très loin parce
que en fait il faut savoir que ce find x
N2 il arrivera absolument pas en France
pas du tout par contre lui le find end
c'est compliqué les noms find n flip je
lis mes notes parce que c'est accouché
dehors et bien lui il va arriver en
France et au pot nous dit qu'il
arriverait à priori au premier trimestre
2023 ça veut dire que au début de
l'année vous allez voir arriver ce
smartphone je pense que ça va être un
truc de fou parce qu'on a déjà vu des
produits qui essayent de se mettre en
face du zflip de Samsung mais avec plus
ou moins de réussite c'est compliqué et
on voit qu'il va y avoir cette année en
tout cas je vous l'assure en 2023 de
plus en plus de constructeurs qui vont
arriver avec des smartphones pliants
mais pas forcément avec ce format là et
c'est aujourd'hui ce format là qui
cartonne je vous ai montré il y a
quelques jours le Xiaomi le mix fold 2
qui est bien mais c'est un peu comme un
folle donc on vient ouvrir et on est
plus grande tablette on a également vu
la version de Honor qui est un peu la
même chose un peu comme un Z fold un peu
grand voyez eux ils vont arriver en
début d'année probablement au mois de
février mais c'est ce format là qui
cartonne aujourd'hui c'est ce format là
que Samsung vend en saut de plein de
sauts de partout des quantités dingues
même si communique pas sur les chiffres
c'est ce format là qu'ils ont et c'est
ce format là qui plaît c'est d'ailleurs
en ce format là que Samsung croit
énormément parce qu'on fait une pub TV
donc je pense que oppo a bien joué son
jeu et très malin là-dessus il nous
propose un truc qui est très cool alors
après je reste quand même avec deux
trois interrogations on voit qu'au
niveau du processeur là où Samsung avait
choisi un snap dragon 8 plus Jen one sur
son Z flip 4 et ils viennent nous
proposer un médiathèque d'emmène City
c'est un 9000 plus c'est le plus haut de
gamme de chez médiathèque il faudra
faire des benchmarks et venir comparer
pour voir lequel va apporter le plus de
performances regardez alors je vous
montre parce que j'ai trouvé une vidéo
sur Youtube où on voit un créateur de
contenu je vais dire chinois parce que
je pense que c'est du mandarin mais une
fois de plus je le lis pas le chinois
donc bon mais à mon avis c'est ça et
unboxing et alors le truc est très très
cool pourquoi alors attendez on va
regarder très rapidement on va passer
voilà regardez ça regardez cet écran
extérieur l'écran extérieur il est
vachement cool quand même et ça je
trouve ça génial parce que une fois de
plus comme on a une surface plus grande
on va pouvoir venir apporter un peu plus
de d'interaction ça sera vachement plus
cool alors le timer effectivement il
vous montre un peu pour voir différents
usages la caméra regarder la différence
par rapport aux zip 4 c'est autre chose
quoi on a quand même vachement plus de
place parce que vous allez faire une
photo vous voyez davantage parce que
vous faites de la vidéo vous avez un
meilleur rendu d'autant plus que les
caméras qui sont vachement intéressantes
sur les caméras extérieures donc là vous
vous filmez vous voyez là c'est cool
parce que vous avez deux caméras une
caméra principale c'est un grand angle
de 50 mégapixels là où samsung vous
propose un grand angle de 12 mégapixels
qui est déjà bien honnêtement mais on va
plus loin et en ultra grand-angle vous
avez un 8 mégapixels alors Samsung c'est
aussi du 12 je sais pas se donner du
dragon mais ce qui va nous intéresser si
c'est pas tant l'ultra grand-angle mais
surtout la qualité principale du
grand-angle en 50 mégapixels tout en
sachant qu'à l'intérieur vous avez
également une caméra de selfie de 32
megapixels Samsung c'est du 10
mégapixels je pense pas que pas grand
chose on va pas réellement utiliser la
caméra intérieure pour venir faire des
selfie c'est la carte extérieurs puisque
vous avez le grand écran donc ça c'est
très cool en termes d'usage parce que
les usages vous allez avoir on a des
usages photos on a des usages vidéos
d'ailleurs la même chose que Samsung
vous mettez la main ça déclenche une
photo la regarder vous montrer quelques
images alors je veux pas en quoi il y a
la différence c'est que ces caméras
intérieur qui avait extérieures il faut
être plus j'en sais rien je lis pas le
mandarin donc il vous montre ça il vous
montre des images donc regardez aussi ça
c'est marrant parce qu'en fait il vous
montre ici que vous pouvez venir
regarder
le smartphone mais je suis pas sûr que
ce soit bon mais sur du Tik Tok
typiquement alors après ça peut-être
dépenses peut-être un réseau social
chinois ça je vais pas vous dire de
bêtises mais je pense que du format TiK
ToK on peut venir le regarder là-dessus
donc on peut consulter du contenu quand
votre smartphone est fermé donc en
utilisant vraiment un format qui est
plus petit donc ça c'est marrant vous
avez un tout petit dans la main et vous
pouvez regarder du contenu regardez
comme il scroll et vous allez voir
qu'une fois qu'il est ouvert regardez le
pull là il va venir l'ouvrir et on n'a
pas perdu énormément de contenu donc ça
reste vachement utilisable et ce truc là
on peut venir l'utiliser également alors
pour des appels téléphoniques pour des
messages ça sera plus grand vous aurez
plus grand clavier vous pourrez pour le
coup réellement répondre et taper à des
messages là donc je trouve ça cool je
trouve ça bien vu et c'était ce qu'il
fallait je me suis dit pourquoi est-ce
que ça me saoule alors qu'ils ont de la
place il nous faut un tout petit écran
alors peut-être que sur le zflip 5 c'est
prévu qu'on ait un plus grand écran il
faudrait parce qu'à mon avis ça va être
très compliqué pour eux ça c'est assez
marrant parce que on peut aussi imaginer
jouer à des petits jeux des petits jeux
vous allez pas me faire ici un fortnite
soyons clair mais on peut imaginer j'en
sais rien moi Angry Birds par exemple un
petit Angry Birds qu'on pourrait avoir
ici ça me paraît pas déconnant donc il y
a des usages et cet écran il est
vraiment cool il apporte vraiment tous
ses usages sont extrêmement important et
je trouve super joli en terme de
finition il est vraiment canon alors on
voit un poil la pliure de toute façon on
va être dans la même chose qu'on a
aujourd'hui avec Samsung on s'en tirage
je pense la pliure sous le doigt le TCL
Chicago je sentais pas trop la pliure
sous le doigt ça c'était assez marrant
de la même manière que avec le oppo find
n que j'ai testé en janvier bah là je la
sentais pas trop la pliure non plus donc
ça c'est assez marrant donc est-ce
qu'ils vont réussir à avoir la même
techno d'écran où on sent pas trop la
peure sur leur finden de flip que son
avait sur le finden première version je
sais pas mais en tout cas ils ont fait
un truc de fou et l'autre truc qui est
dingue et ça je vous l'ai dit avec le
fight pro que j'ai adoré c'est que on a
eu le partenariat avec un seul Blade et
c'était génial alors pour autant avec le
finding 5 Pro on avait la puce Marie
siliconix ici on nous parle pas de puce
Malé siliconics qui a pour le traitement
d'image je pense pas qu'on l'est est-ce
que on va aller aussi loin en termes de
photos que ce qu'on avait avec le
finding 5 Pro ça serait génial mais
peut-être pas en plus ici on aura
directement Android 13 avec coloré
stress donc ça va le faire en termes
d'expérience logiciel on sera carrément
à jour en plus on aura une plus grosse
batterie de 4300 millions d'empereurs
donc avoir également au niveau de
l'autonomie ce que se rend pas compte
bref je trouve ça juste très cool et une
fois de plus un smartphone qui mérite
énormément il est beau les finitions
sont super jolies on voit bien le à sol
Blade écrit au dos ici on va aller quand
il est ouvert il a la gueule je trouve
très joli donc je pense réellement que
ce smartphone le oppo finden de flip il
faut vraiment arrêter les nombres à
coucher dehors les marques à
sérieusement faites-moi un truc plus
condensé j'en sais rien moi au pauvre
fille un flip 2 j'en sais rien en tout
cas ce smartphone je trouve très cool
très sexy on tient enfin le vrai
concurrent du Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4 Z
flip 3 efflicat zip 4 on tient le vrai
concurrent et ça peut faire très mal ça
me saoule alors après aujourd'hui soyons
clairs au pot est une marque même si
elle est très techno même si elle est
très fort elle est pas aussi forte que
ça me saoule en France et en Europe mais
elle est très bonne super marque et si
communique vraiment autour de ce produit
et s'ils arrivent à le distribuer dans
le commerce et que les gens le voient ce
produit là il faut le voir c'est comme
le Galaxy Z flip 4 je vous ai parlé
parce que ils ont fait une pub Samsung
qui est très forte qui tourne en télé je
vous ai fait une vidéo pour vous en
parler parce qu'en fait ce smartphone là
il y a un effet waouh quand on le voit
si on vous dit ouais il y a un
smartphone qui se plie ouais d'accord il
se plie mais si vous le voyez vous
faites ah ouais ok je pense que ce
produit là ils arrivent à le mettre en
magasin s'ils arrivent à mettre dans les
bonnes mains et que les gens le voient
ils diront ah ouais ça c'est cool et
c'est ça qu'il me faut et le tarif là
pour l'instant que j'ai pu voir ça
serait du 800 euros à peu près 800 euros
hors taxes alors attention en France il
y a des taxes la douane l'importation le
recyclage la TVA donc le tarif je pense
qu'il va monter mais à mon avis au pot
va essayer de le positionner à peu près
au même tarif que le Samsung Galaxy Z
flip 4 pro je m'en sors plus c'est non
donc ça c'est cool donc je pense que le
Samsung Galaxy Z flip 4 va avoir du mal
face au pot find N2 flip [ __ ] j'en
peux plus de ces noix couché dehors mais
ça va être cool voilà donc on en
reparlera je vous embrasse prenez soin
de vous dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
surtout en bas dans les commentaires de
l'amour Ciao
[Musique]